they support the blm riots of 2020
almost every member the january 6th
committee did a lot of them supported
the riots in los angeles in 1992. now
they're telling you they oppose riots
but
we have the evidence they've gone on the
record supporting political violence
when it suits them so for example in
1992 jamie raskin of maryland now a
member of the january 6 committee was an
assistant professor at american
university washington college of law he
said he hoped there wouldn't be a quote
backlash to the race riots in los
angeles in 1992. now 63 people were
murdered heavily for their skin color by
the way
there were thousands of injuries there's
a billion dollars in property damage
reginald denny was ripped out of his
truck and beaten nearly to death on
camera but jamie raskin wasn't bothered
by any of this at all what he was
worried about was the rioters
people sensed that justice was not done
in the verdict that came down in the
state criminal court
and you know i would just hope that
president bush doesn't anticipate or
encourage a backlash against the rioting
which followed the verdict
yeah reginald denny what is regional
identity wrong he was hauling a load of
cinder blocks the wrong neighborhood and
he had the wrong skin color so they beat
him almost gave him brain damage but
that's cool
that same year the chairman of the
january 6 committee today that would be
benny thompson decided he couldn't
condemn rioting instead he said he was
worried about injustices
against
black officials
in los angeles at the time well the
injustice was happening on the streets
of la as the city was torched and race
riots were in progress but he couldn't
denounce it
match lap is the chairman of cpac he
joins us tonight matt thanks so much for
coming on so it's it
it's a little much for this very same
the precisely the same people who have
no problem with real political violence
grandstanding and hyperventilating about
what happened on january 6. why does
nobody point this out
yeah and why does it have to be shown on
your show i mean the public records of
these elected officials is there for the
entire media to see the hypocrisy of all
the times they've taken to the floor and
taken to media to say that people like
donald trump were not legitimately
elected presidents all the times they
have not condemned violence or in this
case you have the chairman of the
committee and this other member from
maryland basically saying
oh riots are fine if you have a social
grievance now
why is it okay for jamie raskin to go to
the floor of the house of
representatives in 2016
and say that donald trump was not
legitimately elected that this ranking
this chairman betty thompson can say
that donald trump is illegitimate and
and boycott his inauguration but when a
retired teacher or a mom or a dad or
somebody wants to go to their capital
and protest what they saw as an election
rife with lots of questions and
fraudulent voting
somehow that's there's something
untoward with their desire to speak up
why can't they also speak up and why did
benny thompson say that josh hawley and
ted cruz should be on the no-fly list
for raising legitimate questions about
the 2020 election this two-tier justice
system this two-tiered idea that if
you're a conservative or you're a
republican or you're a trump supporter
you get through this kind of ghetto
justice and if you are somebody else
who has these progressive views it's
fine it's just agreement but it's not
right to express
most americans don't have the time to
kind of follow this they send some
things really amiss that's why they vote
for members of the united states senate
to represent their views they're
interested in safe from the overreach of
lunatics like benny thompson and liz
cheney so where is mitch mcconnell and
lindsey graham shoot more trump voters
like what
don't normal people deserve
representation
yeah absolutely and i think that's part
of the the questions on all this which
is if you want to ask real questions
about one six why don't we ask them why
don't we find out the reason why the
capitol police force we just found out
through our foia this week because of
tom fitton at judicial watch that the
capitol police going into 1-6 was that
50 strength how come that was allowed to
happen how come that was okay we all
knew it was going to be a tumultuous
emotional day these are the questions
they don't want to answer you know why
tucker because when the political
violence benefits them they just turned
a blind eye toward it when real
americans have outrage they want to put
them in jail yeah i've noticed match
that thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight